ciao mariners e benvenuti in questo
nuovissimo video
innanzitutto ci tenevo a scusarmi
tantissimi misti massimo per la mia
assenza
qui su youtube ho pubblicato poco in
questi giorni perché ero malata morta
per due settimane sul letto con
l'influenza
chi mi segue su instagram avrà visto le
mie storie quindi ci sono le prove
ragazzi non mi sto mentendo
ma chiaramente ora sono guarita quindi
sono tornata sono attiva e continuerò a
pupi nizio a pubblicare video a raffica
detto questo partire subito con il video
che ovviamente come potete vedere parla
di san valentino
in particolare mi avete chiesto di
raccontarti degli episodi dei miei san
valentino passati top e flop
io ne ho selezionati per voi 21 top e
uno flop e partirei subito da quello top
così vi lascio con il come al solito con
questa nota di amarezza del manettino
flop così v vi sentirete meno sole in
questo san valentino che sicuramente
andrà meglio di come è andato quello che
vi racconterò allora il mio san
valentino top in realtà e cioè è stato
top per questo piccolo gesto era fatto
questo ragazzo che nella sua semplicità
è stato molto molto apprezzato a per
raccontarvi questo episodio del mio
samani tiro top
vi devo anche raccontare insomma in
quale situazione sentimentale mi trovavo
ai tempi si parla di quando avevo più o
meno 15 16 anni stavo con un ragazzo da
qualche mese
lui era ad un anno più grande di me e
andavamo in scuole diverse quindi ci
vedevamo solo nel weekend
in particolare ogni tanto cioè
occasione proprio speciale andavamo a
ballare il sabato sera in discoteca
quindi poi il sabato prima di salvare tv
salentino era accadeva come quest'anno
in settimana di settimana quindi il
sabato prima ronda t a ballare soltanto
noi due di solito andavamo in gruppo che
c'è quella volta non soltanto dei due
quindi era ancora più emozionante
sentivo tutta tira da tacco non so 12
quindi che non mi ricordo comunque
importante già i tempi e nel momento in
cui dopo un'ora di coda varco la soglia
della discoteca voi non ci crederete
aveva un piede dentro e l'altro fuori
dalla discoteca mi si spezza il tacco
allora io ancora oggi mi chiedo come
diavolo è potuto accadere mai fatto che
io entro nel panico perché comunque ero
dentro la discoteca
cioè se uscivo dovevo rifare la coda
comunque uscivo devo ritrovare a casa
perdevo un'ora era meglio che tornasse a
casa direttamente e rimanesse lì oppure
miss pensavo anche l'altro tacco è
iniziato a fare il tip tap sul cubo
alla fine la soluzione migliore era
chiamare la mia amica la mia migliore
amica che era a casa non era uscita
quella sera e chiedere questo favore
della vita di portarmi i tacchi nei
tempi aveva il motorino quindi sono
stata super fortunato perché arriva
tutti col pony davanti alla discoteca
con le scarpe e mi ha salvato la vita
quindi poi la serata continuate è stato
tutto carino era una delle prime serie
che andavamo ballare soltanto noi due
quindi era moto molto emozionante dopo
quella serata
qualche giorno dopo era san valentino io
ero a scuola in classe e mi arriva un
messaggio allora hanno anche questo
video spiegare non so se esiste ancora
però ai tempi di cui andavo a scuola
c'era il lago che era un giornalino
gratuito che davano in metro o sui
pullman che
lasciamolo lì pacchioni uno poteva
prendere la sua copia gratuitamente io
lo prendevo per leggere l'oroscopo di
solito ente in classe ne giravano sempre
due o tre distilo messaggio il mio
fidanzato dei tempi di scrive legge vai
sulla pagina numero non mi ricordo di
dell'ego io prendo il cubo sfoglio e
c'era una pagina dedicata appunto al ai
messaggi alle dediche romantiche per san
valentino e lui mi aveva fatto questa
dedica che niente di epocale però aveva
fatto stati acer aveva scritto tipo
l'altra sera eri bellissima nonostante
il tacco rotto buon san valentino amore
ti voglio tanto bene e il suo nome è
niente quello era un gesto semplice
questo è l'esempio di un gesto semplice
senza fare niente di epocale che però
cioè fa la differenza perché comunque ai
tempi soprattutto che eravamo ragazzini
figure in classe con tutte le compagnie
dio cosa successe vai a vedere cioè
erano tutte lì i lacrimoni perché lui
aveva fatto questo gesto super carino e
e niente io avevo pensato molto più di
qualsiasi regalo perché obiettivamente
ai tempi cioè magari potrò neanche
permettere a uno dei ragazzini e e
quindi niente questo ripensando che
siamo agli anni passati è stato un
episodio molto carino e quindi ci tenevo
a raccontarvelo passiamo il san
valentino flop e per raccontarvi san
marino flop è meglio che questo
palloncino sparisca delle mie mani ma
soprattutto dalle mie unghie perché non
voleva che raccontandovi e l'episodio
dal nervoso insomma lo facesse esplodere
allora insomma rentino flop
riguarda insomma una storia che non era
stata insomma ufficializzata quindi io
ero presa una cotta per questo ragazzo
che si era lasciato da un po di mesi e
uscivamo uscivamo insieme messaggini
uscivamo dalla sua compagnia li
riportava a casa mi veniva prendere
quindi arriva a san valentino io vado
nel panico perché oddio cioè lo dobbiamo
festeggiare o non lo dobbiamo
festeggiare pathos ansia cosa decide di
far marina gli organizza una cena
romantica a casa per san valentino
perché non si sa così mi sono svegliato
ma facciamo così ha venduto lui accetta
l'invito quindi come direbbe maria ha
accettato l'invito quindi si è
presentato la regia di era una buona
cosa
apro la porta e aveva questo mazzo di
rose rosse casa ma allora è amore ma
cioè sposiamoci scusa cosa stiamo
aspettando
entra io contentissimo per le rose ci
mettiamo a tavola io ho cucinato e tutto
bruciamo tutto carino tutto perfetto
musica romantica insomma stava andando
tutto da dio
arriva il momento in cui insomma ci
mettiamo a vedere la tv sul divano
iniziamo a baciarci e da che era una
persona si è trasformata in un altra
cioè io non lo riconoscevo più quindi lo
guardo e dico ma tutto bene è successo
qualcosa lo so mi puzza la shell
qual è il problema riguarda mi fa non ce
la faccio
che senso no perché io io penso ancora
lei cosa stai scherzando
cioè no non ho capito fi scusa cosa stai
pensando ancora lei chi alla tua ex vi
siete lasciati da mesi sei qui con me
sei venuto a cena da me ne guardo le
rose ci sentiamo tutti i giorni perché
stai pensando a lei
while cosa perché non me l'ha comunicato
prima ma ci si tutta sta cosa questo è
quello che avrei dovuto dire ma ero
troppo preso mai della situazione quindi
invece dirgli questo lo consolato gli ha
detto tranquillo non fa niente
va bene così il pro insomma lo
tranquillizzava che poi di cosa che era
venuto a sbattere a calci fuori da casa
mia mi ha ringraziato e mi ha detto sei
davvero una grande amica
[Musica]
ecco io in quel momento non esisteva
ancora la parola franzò ma cioè
e quel momento ero la regina della
franzoni cioè sono stata incoronata e
questo video si conclude così con questa
immagine di una marina pranzo nantes e
alla grande e mi auguro vivamente che il
vostro san valentino non abbia niente a
che vedere con il mio san valentino
super iper flop che vi ho appena
raccontato cover solito se vi è piaciuto
il video ricordatevi di lasciarmi un bel
commentino di mettervi un bel like e se
non avete ancora fatto
iscrivetevi al canale e attivate la
campanella vicino al tasso d'iscrizione
per rimanere sempre aggiornati su tutti
nei nuovi video ma soprattutto seguitemi
su tutti gli altri social facebook music
hall e instagram
vi mando un bacione e ci vediamo al
prossimo video ticos parlerà forse san
valentino
[Musica]